[Música]
tardes a todos de verdad estoy sumamente
feliz de estar aquí y darle la
oportunidad de hablar un poco sobre lo
que me apasiona el movimiento la
educación física del deporte
seis de cada diez de que estaremos
hablando
cuatro de cada diez
estos números realmente les va a
emocionar o les va a preocupar seis de
cada diez escuelas según el estado de la
educación no tienen educación física
cuatro estudiantes de cada diez no
disfrutan de ese privilegio
yo sé que no me lo están preguntando
pero
siete de cada diez mujeres en costa rica
no practican actividad física del todo
hay que recordar que se necesita nada
más 60 minutos vigorosos o 120 minutos
para poder considerarse una persona
activa
realmente a mí como lo pudieron observar
soy un poco activa me preocupa porque
cuando yo estaba en la escuela la
oportunidad de moverme era esencial
en el kinder quería ser la mujer más
veloz del mundo en la escuela quería
hacerla claudia paul del 96 y colgarme
una medalla de oro
claramente uno de mis sueños era
representar a mi país
en el colegio lo único que deseaba era
ser jugadora profesional de fútbol e ir
a un mundial
gracias al deporte estoy aquí hablando
con ustedes y decirles que el deporte
nos puede ayudar no solamente a su ayuda
profesional integral sino también
aprender de la vida
en el 2010 tuve la oportunidad de
representar a mi país
fui a alemania corrí salté les puedo
decir que no solamente en la cancha sino
que de carmen cama porque estaba
cumpliendo mi sueño
tan temido nacional halle un poco de
camisas pero sobre todo aprendí a vivir
claramente costa rica no fue el campeón
mundial de ese año
claramente mi lágrimas y mi frustración
me hizo pensar en qué momento decidí
estar aquí
pero al fin y al cabo les puedo decir
bienvenidos a la vida
en el 1978 desde
1978 le estoy hablando de hace muchos
años la organización nacional la
organización de las naciones unidas
recalca la práctica de la educación
física la actividad física y el deporte
es un derecho fundamental para todos
hicimos un ejercicio antes de esto es
muy poco levantaron las manos
pero bueno si hablamos de la unicef
nombre carga que la educación física y
el movimiento es importante para el
desarrollo integral de los estudiantes y
recordemos los números seis de cada diez
escuelas no reciben esto para un 4 de
cada 10 estudiantes ni para qué
hablarles del sedentarismo las mujeres
hoy lejos de también invitarlos a hacer
actividad física vamos a movernos ahí
donde ustedes están voy a pedir a todos
y todas que cierren los ojos iban a
empezar a moverse
van a cerrar los ojos y vamos a ir a
donde dejamos ese tesoro que hace muchos
años
dejamos olvidado quiera jugar allí donde
están vamos a empezar a mover las manos
quiero ver a todos las manos moviendo
las manos moviendo las manos
y a partir de ahora abro mis brazos los
nuevos de un lado los modos del otro
empiezo a nadar empiezan a dar empiezo a
nadar empiezan a dar tiempo
2 x 2
listo pasamos la siguiente prueba vamos
para atrás vamos para atrás nada más
para atrás vamos para atrás tiempo
costa rica con quien limita
muy bien perfecto no hay dónde estoy
modo los pies modos los pies modelos que
demos los pies rápido que no van a
llegar rápido que no van a llegar rápido
que van a llegar tiempo congelados
porque el pirata nos quieren robar
nuestro tesoro
me escondo mejor no me escondo me
escondo
cuidado
cuidado la capital de costa rica
la capital de costa rica
que es muy bien creo que hemos llegado
al último reto y más importante todo de
pie todos de pie vamos arriba y arriba
los piernas los brazos no las piernas o
los brazos volumen más rápido que están
cerca de alcanzar el tesoro
nos vamos a sentar
vamos a mover nuestros manos otra vez
llegamos
en cuestión de un minuto les enseñe que
podemos jugar donde estamos
porque los docentes no podemos darle
esta oportunidad a nuestros estudiantes
hay que recordar y hay que jugar con la
mente de nuestros niños ilusionario es
volver a contarles esta historia y el
alejandro morera soto más de 18.000
personas rompieron el récord por haber a
22 mujeres dar alma vida y corazón
este mismo año germán en los
paralímpicos se colgó una medalla de oro
pero bueno hay que empezar a activarse
realmente son pasos muy sencillos pero
esenciales nosotros como docentes
tenemos que empezar a crear espacios
seguros para que nuestros estudiantes
puedan motivarse tener un desarrollo
continuo no solamente en las clases de
educación física sino poner este
movimiento en sus clases de matemáticas
sociales cívica y por qué no español
jugar
experimentar
incentivar y nosotros como docentes
motivar para que este movimiento llegue
a sus casas a su comunidad y bajar esos
números
y al final lo que queremos también con
el deporte es tener una igualdad de
género para que esas niñas que quieran
jugar fútbol taekwondo gimnasia huesos
niños que quieren practicar baloncesto
volibol o al humano tengamos las mismas
oportunidades
realmente yo tuve al mejor profesor de
educación física
inicio valenciano que gracias a él estoy
aquí contando la historia de como el
movimiento me ayudó a vivir
hoy los estoy invitando a ustedes
agarrar un poquito de su tiempo en sus
clases
activarlos
ser personas de cambio pero sobre todo
ser flexibles
los retos a partir de hoy que empiecen
por lo menos unos 10 minutos
porque realmente tenemos que recordar
que el deporte la educación y la
recreación son esenciales para el
desarrollo integral de los niños estoy
seguro que con esos 10 minutos de
movimiento seremos los nuevos
superhéroes de la infancia pues está
licencia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias por la
excelente presentación
una pregunta el fútbol de las mujeres ha
mejorado muchísimo en los últimos años y
no sólo en la calidad del fútbol en la
manera que lo percibe la gente
yo me pregunto por qué no le hacen más
énfasis al hecho de que las mujeres
y no se tiran al piso no se revuelcan no
hacen juegan cuando se caen es porque
las votaron pero pero no no lo dicen
suficiente porque yo creo que realmente
nosotras como mujeres hemos pasado por
donde asustan siempre lo he dicho
siempre hemos tenido que nadar contra
contra la corriente y creo que todas las
mujeres que representan
al país a su ciudad en algún deporte
cultura o música saben que para llegar
ahí hay que hay que luchar y no queremos
dar ese paso atrás y claramente es por
eso que estos espacios son sumamente
importantes para toda la población niños
adultos personas pensionadas educadores
directores porque pueden darse cuenta
que el deporte puede llegar a hacer
cambios entonces
este storytelling que uno puede expresar
aquí
hace que motivemos a todas las mujeres a
que si nos votan una vez hay que
levantarse diez
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]